Mary here we have a lot of release dates
revealed today so we rounded them all up
in the news update minecraft will be
coming to PlayStation 4 PlayStation Vita
and Xbox one in August the xbox one and
ps4 versions will be available for
twenty dollars you'll also be able to
import your savegame from xbox 360 and
ps3 to xbox one or ps4 respectively
additionally in August the PlayStation
Vita version of Minecraft will be tied
to the ps3 edition meaning everyone who
bought minecraft playstation 3 edition
from PSN will get it on Vita for free
saves will be transferable between the
ps3 and PS Vita no exact date was
announced for any of the minecraft
releases Turtle Rock Studios upcoming
multiplayer shooter evolved drop some
very specific details today the game
will be released on october 21st this
year for playstation 4 xbox one and pc
if you haven't heard much about this
game check out GameSpot's preview it's a
team game that has four class-based
hunters attacking a fifth player who
plays as the monster lastly in Reverse
release date news the developer of
Fallout and the Elder Scrolls Bethesda
has dashed hopes of fallout 4 III
announcement saying on Twitter quote the
says to Game Studios will not be talking
about its next game for a long time
tsarni Bethesda for more gaming news
check out gamespot com
you